what are your thoughts about
the efforts of elon musk and spacex and
pushing this commercial
space flight and i mean other companies
axiom space as well what are your
thoughts on
um on their efforts it's like a gold
rush uh it's a space race 2.0 there's a
lot of terms for it the new space race i
think it's fabulous i think it is
it's moving at a pace that is
unprecedented and also has a lot of
investment from the commercial and
private sector pushing it forward so
elon most notoriously doing a lot of it
just himself with spacex so we've worked
really closely with the spacex ops teams
and medical team uh planning the
inspiration for mission and now some of
the polaris missions which are happening
and jared isaacman has been a fabulous
colleague collaborator pilot for the
missions you know we're doing again
we're doing the same deep profiling and
molecular characterization of these
astronauts as we've done for
scott kelly and other astronauts there
from nasa
and we're seeing so far actually
there'll be a lot of this presented
later this year it seems like
it's pretty safe again there's dangers
we can see real stress on the body very
obvious changes some of the same changes
that scott kelly experienced but for the
most part they returned back to normal
even for a short three-day mission i
remember chatting with with jared and we
were presenting the data to them
actually just a few weeks ago kind of a
briefing to the crew
and because they went to 590 kilometers
they went basically several hundred
kilometers higher than the space station
or the hubble you normally wrestle more
radiation the farther you get from earth
there's more radiation he was worried
you know did we get cooked it was kind
of his question for me in the briefing
it actually looks like you can go back
into the microwave you didn't get fully
cooked you can go a little bit farther
so for the polaris mission they're going
to go even farther
uh and then also
open the hatch and go on these new
spacesuits that spacex is designing
that'll be much nimbler not as much of a
giant you know
dr octagon kind of uh spacesuit but
really um
like looks like just a nice spaceship
they're gonna go out into the vacuum of
space
and so you know pushing all the
engineering uh for these missions which
are privately funded so it's it's people
who just say i want to go up in space
and see if i can push the limits has
been fabulous but i think the most
fabulous part is is jared in particular
but others other commercials space
flight drivers like john schaffner peggy
whitson for the axiom missions are
coming to us the scientists researchers
saying i don't just want to go up into
space just to hang out how much science
can i get done when i'm up there what
can i do what experiments can i do give
me you know blood tissue urine semen
tears i'll give you any biofluid uh you
know and i i always i email them back
and say listen every one of your cells
is worthy of study i send you know so i
have this really kind of creepy
geneticist email responsible like i want
all of your cells you know but but it's
true because there's so much we don't
know
i want to learn as much as we can about
every every time i go up anyone so we're
doing it you know with nasa astronauts
but it's been suddenly this influx of
new crews that are willing to do almost
anything right so including we did skin
biopsies for the inspiration for crew
before and after space flight and that's
never been done before we've never seen
the structure of the skin and how it
changes in response to microgravity and
also the microbes that change and so
these beautiful images of even the
structure of skin changing and the
inflammation that we've seen in like for
scott kelly for example we now have a
molecule by molecule map of what happens
to skin
which has never been done before so
there what are interesting surprises
there so one of the things we can see
the part what's driving inflammation is
we can actually see macrophages as other
dendritic cells pieces like cells that
are part of the immune system kind of
creeping along towards the surface of
the skin which is now we know it's
actually physically driving the immune
system as these cells going and creating
this inflammation which is what leads to
some of the rashes but we didn't see as
much in them as we saw for example some
of the signatures of scott kelly so
we can see within the crew who's getting
more of a rash or not or who didn't
experience any rash
and some people had
changes in vision some people had you
know other
gi problems uh even you know even
looking at what happens to the gut and
looking at the microbiome the gut other
people didn't so we able to see and
start to get a little bit predictive
about our medicine right now we're just
diagnosing but it'd be good to say uh if
you're going into space here's exactly
what you need for each bacteria in your
body here's what you could really take
to get rid of nausea or other ways we
can monitor you to keep keep the
inflammation down
what does it take to prepare for one of
these missions because you mentioned
some of the folks are not necessarily
lifelong astronauts you're talking about
more and more regular civilians what's
what does it take physiologically and
psychologically to prepare for these
they have to do a lot of the same
training that most astronauts do so a
lot of it's in hawthorne at spacex
headquarters which if you can ever get a
chance to do a tour is fabulous it's
really you can see all these giant
rockets being built and then we're
drawing blood over there right next to
them so it's a really cool place but the
the training they have to go through a
lot of the ops a lot of the programming
just in case most of the systems are
automated on the dragon and other
spacecraft but
just in case so they have to go through
all the majority of the training
if you want to go to the space station
as the axiom missions are including john
schruffner you have to do a training for
some of the russian modules and if you
don't do that training then you're not
allowed to go to the russian part of the
space station apparently so right now
john schaffner for example unless he
completes this additional training all
in russian he's not allowed all in
russia who has to learn enough russian
to be you know just wow so it's not just
technical he also has
enough enough russia enough enough
russian and uh so it's a and if he
doesn't learn he can't go to that part
of the space station so interesting
things like that but you'll be you know
it's not that far like oh i can see it
right there i can't float over to that
that capsule uh but technically he can't
go so you know is there a
chinese components to this the
international space station is their
collaboration there sadly not they're
building uh their own space station uh
i'm glad they're building a space
station actually eventually there'll be
probably four space stations in orbit by
2028 some from the orbital reef some
from lockheed martin of course axiom is
far ahead right now they're probably
gonna be done first
but the
the extraordinary thing is
uh
there's unfortunately there's no
collaboration between the you see that
as a negative that's not the positive
kind of competition it's it's a good
question so maybe
as for example when we get different
nasa grants you apply for a grant you
get to the lab it goes you know to go
through cornell the grants office i have
to sign as a scientist as the pi on the
mission say i promise i will move no
funds or resources or any staff to
anyone in china or work with anyone in
china with these dollars that you're
giving to the lab for this mission and
so like every other grant i get from
that nasa dod or sorry do you let me go
back to that
every other grant i get from say the nih
or the nsf even symptoms dod you don't
have to promise that you won't talk to
anybody in china about it but for nasa
alone it's congressionally mandated you
have to promise and sign all this
paperwork so i can't do anything with
anyone in china about this and what i
view is sad about that is i want to at
least be able to chat with them about it
and know what they're up to but we can't
you know even
go to a conference in china technically
with nasa funds about say space medicine
or engineering a new rocket i i can't go
i could go with personal funds but i
can't use those funds like you should be
able to go to a conference and in a
friendly way talk [ __ ] yeah yeah just
yeah we're doing like like the way
scientists do really well which is like
they complement but it's a backhanded
compliment like uh like you're doing a
really good job here and then you kind
of imply that you're doing much better
job that's the core of competition you
get jealous and then you everybody's
trying to improve but that you're
ultimately talking you're ultimately
collaborating closely you're competing
closely as opposed to in your own silos